this one this fellow my lap so before I
even get into this let me make something
very clear I am NOT a guy with a with
inside information I'm not a guy with an
inside track I'm not a guy with sources
however I have come basically into some
knowledge that I do believe I have
required reason to believe I have no
reason to doubt and it is gonna be
anonymous you know from from me to you
folks so you know obviously take it with
a grain of salt but I have absolutely no
reason to doubt this information and it
makes me kind of a guy like I never have
inside information so I kind of want to
share it so Superman Henry Cavill the
future of Superman is still very much in
flux as far as what is being said
publicly because Jeff Jones was asked
actually not long ago and his answer was
basically don't hold your breath on
another Superman film and you know
obviously right now Henry Cavill he's
busy you know promoting of the new
Mission Impossible which he's in so he's
not saying much about it either and
certainly up up until recently a sequel
to Man of Steel did not look like much
like that was ever gonna happen and a
sequel to Justice League at this point
looks honestly even less likely because
as much as Man of Steel didn't make as
much money as they had wanted it to Man
of Steel was not as expensive as Justice
League was so just looking at the
numbers you know I would say a follow-up
the Man of Steel would be more likely to
get cleared than a sequel to justice Lee
just looking at what they cost versus
what they what it caused versus and what
they made but all the word all the
official word is
we don't know probably not the
information that I've gotten is that
they're actually quietly but very intent
on retaining kaavo and getting him
behind a superhero movie for a couple of
reasons one being mission impossible
fallout that combined with the much
better reaction to his Superman in
Justice League and I think or know that
this is not I think the information I
have is that the feeling is that cavils
star is on the rise especially coming
out of Mission Possible fallout and it
is really and they want to retain him
before it goes somewhere else because
there is word of him possibly being
considered to replace Daniel Craig to
play James Bond and if he lands another
major franchise that could be at
scheduling could become such a nightmare
that they lose him and they won't want
to do that they are going to want to
lock him down into a contract for more
of these films and get them in
production so that it's tangible and he
can't leave because if he if his star
goes on the rise coming out of Mission
Possible fallout and he lands bond
Warner Brothers and the DC movies are
gonna look like the biggest idiots on
the planet for letting him walk away
they do not want to let him do that
so that's the information that I have
but again I do believe it I do trust it
but again I'm not a guy you come to for
inside information so grain assault
still but I have I have no reason to
doubt this information and I do trust it
so getting more into speculation here
this is me extrapolating oh ok so there
was one other thing that was attached to
that because of how executives tend to
think they latch onto the names of the
moment they whether or not an offer ever
goes out whether or not it gets
taken no clue but Warner Brothers wants
to talk to Christopher McQuarrie about
doing Man of Steel 2 if their name
doesn't ring a bell director of mission
impossible 5 & 6 in other words the guy
who just made the film that it is
believed by some folks have Warner
Brothers that will skyrocket Cavill star
so pairing them up again makes total
sense especially you know from executive
logic so now moving out of the
information that I have and getting more
just speculation based on it what I
think we can expect I think we can
expect a director and a probably not a
not a release year announcement because
wisely Warner Brothers has gotten a lot
cager about that I'm not just announcing
a date as soon as they announce a
project I mean they've got a ton of
stuff that they've announced they're
working on with no dates on it but I
would expect that quite possibly before
the end of this year that we will get an
announcement of Man of Steel 2 if they
can get Christopher McQuarrie they will
whether or not he's interested who knows
but if they can get him they will and
they will start to push that in because
even though right now for them they are
they are banking on Wonder Woman and
Aquaman which is doing quite well in
early tests to to save this universe
they know that the fact that they
haven't gotten Superman right is kind of
a blot on things and I they they know
that I believe so I I would expect that
Man of Steel to Christopher McQuarrie or
no but Man of Steel 2 with Henry Cavill
gets announced as something being in
development before the years over for my
money they would aim for 2020 release on
that because for what they've got
actually locked down
is not much this year we've got Aquaman
2019 we have Wonder Woman 1980 form we
have Shazam they haven't officially
announced 2020 stuff yet
I mean they're working on the Batman
they're working on the the thing that
that har they client they're either
calling Cotham city sirens maybe they're
calling a bird of birds of prey I think
the woman birds of prey and the Harley
Quinn thing we're actually separate
projects I think they merged I can't
even keep trying about anymore but
they've got the Joker stuff that they've
worked on that God they've got all this
stuff but we haven't gotten anything
announced for 2020 yet and Superman is
the kind of thing that they would
fast-track and I could see them
announcing before the end this year for
a late 2020 release and that that second
party that's me I think I'm the most
iffy on that but I I think that if if
they can retain him if I mean if they
lose them they lose him but if they can
retain him they are going to announce
Man of Steel 2 before the end via so
yeah that's kind of it and like I said I
never get inside information so I was
excited so there you go
so yeah your thoughts on Man of Steel -
this is something you want is this
something you'd be excited for do you
think it's a stupidest idea ever do you
think I'm completely just made this up I
didn't but how trustworthy do I come
across as I don't know I really hope
this does try out to be right because uh
otherwise my one time being like I have
inside information if it turns out to be
completely wrong that credibility is
gone and then we're gonna be able to
pull that one again but in any case
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about you know all the stuff - do I
have a patreon that's kind of a big one
but there's links for a bunch of other
stuff it's all down in the description
so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]